President Vladimir Putin was brief and
decisive in tone shortly after he
launched more than 80 missiles at
Targets across Ukraine with activity
it is impossible not to respond this
morning massive strikes took place on
air sea and land against energy and
Military targets against Ukraine if such
attempts by Ukraine continue there will
be harsh responses
those attempts refer to an explosion on
Saturday but damaged the catch Bridge
linking Crimea to the Russian mainland
Putin's Deputy chairman for the National
Security Council
Medvedev said the blast was an act of
terrorism that wouldn't pass and
punished describing Russia's missile
strikes on Monday as episode one both
threatened further and harsh action if
Russia is attacked again recent
Battlefield setbacks in Ukraine have
damaged the image of Russia's leaders
and some analysts say Moscow wanted to
show what its forces are still capable
of although its options seem more
limited of course other attacks in the
coming days because they have been
happening from time to time during the
entire of this conflict but I don't
believe that Russia has the capacity to
send as much missiles deep into Ukraine
as the today on uh day to day by day
basis so I believe it's going to be a
one-time kind of response a Revenge
attack but Putin's Ally in Belarus said
his country was a target of what he
called Ukraine terrorist plots and was
ready to respond
tell the president of Ukraine and the
other lunatics if any of them are still
there that the Crimean bridge will seem
to them like a walk in the park if they
ever touch a single square meter of our
territory with their dirty hands ome
lukasenko announced the creation of a
Joint Force with Russia to defend his
country's border with Ukraine the
European union says it would respond
developments that some fear could lead
to a regional escalation in the conflict
Muhammad al-jazeera Moscow